[Music]  the nice house on the lake is an  apocalyptic horror story it's a story  about a group of friends invited to a  beautiful house on a secluded lake and  it's a story of the secret of the friend  who invited them all there i think the  nice house on the lake speaks to some of  the isolation that we've all felt in  these last few years one of the most fun  things in working on this project is  getting to dig into  some of my deepest insecurities about  myself and my deepest insecurities about  the world that i live in the world that  we all live in today  i wanted to really tap into that sense  of isolation not just from self but from  the society we all live in that core  human feeling of when you know that  everything is falling apart all around  you do you try to take a moment to find  peace for yourself or do you try to  actually actively fight back and make a  better world  [Music]  you